silence to remember
sarah they'd been told not to come
but at six pm when the vigil should have
been starting
hundreds surrounded the bandstand in
clapham common
crowds were then urged to leave instead
they stayed
and what began as a peaceful moment of
[Applause]
mourning
more of a protest for some
[Applause]
people are angry specifically women this
is a vigil this is just supposed to be
everyone paying their respects it's a
sharing of grief
um people are unhappy we came down to
show our respect
to pay our respects and to show that
we we shouldn't be stopped from doing
whatever we want to do
we won't be limited by it as far as the
police came you know they're there the
presence is felt
and i think the presence of the people
is felt as well
and at the heart of it is sarah and
that's all we should all focus on really
and keep our minds on her
the unofficial event unfolded on the day
wayne cousins appeared at westminster
magistrates court
charged with the kidnap and murder of
sarah everard
he sat in a grey tracksuit with his head
bowed as details of the case against him
were read out
the serving police officer who's 48 was
charged on friday night
after confirmation came that the remains
found in woodland near ashford in kent
were those of the 33 year old marketing
executive
the court heard how sarah was seen on
cctv
a number of times as she walked home on
the night of march the third
during that journey she spoke to her
boyfriend on the phone for 14 minutes
but since that call there's been no
further activity on her mobile
and it's yet to be found
to hold the vigil had been refused by
the police
due to lockdown rules and a failed
attempt to get that decision overthrown
in the high court
led organisers to cancel but all day
people came
among them the duchess of cambridge who
wanted to pay her respects
from day one of planning we had things
in place covered marshalls with support
from the council um
teams of stewards and we'd received all
sorts of
uh you know donations of hives jackets
and things like that to support that
process
and obviously now none of that will be
in place and
and that that is a real shame because we
could have tried to guarantee people
safety to an extent
but the metropolitan police said there
were other safe ways to mourn sarah
adding in a statement we take no joy in
this event being cancelled
but it's the right thing to do given the
real and present threat of covert 19
but it was quite clear that there was a
need for many to come
and highlight the safety fears many
women feel as they walk the streets
when people are questioning the police's
approach to dealing with violence
against women and their
responsibility to take these crimes
seriously
i just think it's a bit tone-deaf of
them frankly and i really hope that
there's some soul-searching going on in
the met today about how they've got this
wrong
searches by forensic teams continued
throughout the day in kent
as it emerged in court that sarah's
remains had been found in a builder's
bag
and were identified using dental records
the man accused of killing her will
appear at the old bailly on tuesday
but his cousins prepared for another
night in a cell
in clapham as across the country candles
were lit in sarah's memory
the moment chosen 9 30 p.m
close to the time on that dreadful night
a week and a half ago
when sarah was last seen alive emma
birchley sky news